Pokemon go is huge and everyone is
playing it the more people walking
around an augmented reality means the
more opportunity for something weird to
happen here are the seven craziest real
life things that have happened from
Pokemon go one man Boone Sheridan lives
in an old church in Massachusetts which
to his surprise was turned into a
Pokemon gym players had been spending
the weekend parked outside his place
even blocking his driveway must have
been a pretty intense experience for
someone who didn't know what pokemon go
was Boone seemed to be taking it with a
sense of humor though even getting a
picture with a guy who owned his gym
Pokemon go brings people to all sorts of
places and some are more appropriate
than others the Holocaust Museum along
with many other landmarks is a poke a
stop that means a bunch of people were
walking into the museum to get pokemon a
player even encountered in unsettling
Pokemon coughing in the museum's helena
rubinstein auditorium the image is now
deleted so there's no telling if the
Pokemon really was there but there's no
denying people were throwing down lures
and watching people flock in to
capitalize on the Pokemon the museum
communication director is currently
looking into how to get the museum
excluded from the game but as of now
it's still available in the app
searching for Pokemon can actually put
you in danger if you're not paying
attention like putting yourself in the
middle of a busy street but a guy found
more than he bargained for when he found
himself in a situation where he looked
like he was in a drug deal the 40-year
old reddit user sloth of doom found
himself at a park at 3am as you do when
he was approached by two as he states
sketchy guys turns out they were playing
too and they had a good chat about the
game but then a cop pulled up thinking
there was something illegal going on
after explaining the situation
everything calmed down the cop even
joined in on the fun downloading the app
himself it's a good ending to an all too
troubling tale where people are presumed
to be getting into no good Pokemon go is
perfect for people just waiting around
you could probably grab a few if you're
patient enough but this father to be
found his wife going into labor was the
perfect opportunity to catch a Pidgey
the imgur caption states when your wife
is about to have a baby and a Pokemon
shows up and you have to Loki catch it
that kid wasn't even in the world yet
but he already had father of the year
Pokemon go tells you to be aware of your
surroundings when playing but people
still find themselves falling on the
sidewalks and getting into danger in
o'fallon missouri for teens were caught
staking out spots known to be popular
for the game and then robbing the
players police said the suspects they
have in custody may have been involved
in nearly a dozen robberies the police
got suspicious with the large amount of
people near gas station it just wasn't
normal the four robbers use their
knowledge of the game to ambush victims
at spots they knew would draw players
and picked relatively secluded spots for
the crimes a reminder to everyone to
look around and know where you are at
all times
xavier soch and Seth Ortega were
downtown fullerton hunting Pokemon
socius game froze you know as they do
and they had to hang out for a bit and
then they saw a man who appeared to be
scaring woman and her three sons they
followed the creepy dude and eventually
saw him grabbing the kid so they
detained him and then they learned
authorities had a warrant out for his
arrest for attempted murder that guy is
now locked up and so she's still playing
pokemon go walking around and waiting
for the next chance to be a hero a
Wyoming teen decided to visit the river
in search for Pokemon what she found
instead was a dead body shayla Wiggins
jumped a fence looking for Pokemon when
she came across something in the water
she said the body was floating about
three feet from the shore and it looked
like an average-sized male body police
came shortly after and confirmed it was
in fact a dead body detectives say the
body had been there for less than 24
hours the teen was shaken but says she's
okay now we actually don't know if she
ever caught that Pokemon well those are
the craziest things that have happened
so far but who knows what can happen
next so stay tuned to gamespot for the
latest on Pokemon go